okay um this is why I always want people
to believe me because of this event I
think I was in fifth grade I was in
Taiwan my mom's like don't don't flush
the toilet oh no no no make sure to
flush the toilet okay
I go first I take a [ __ ] there's [ __ ] in
the toilet though okay yeah so then I
flush the toilet there's no [ __ ] my dad
goes in the bathroom and then comes out
my mom goes in after like 30 minutes and
go why didn't you flush the toilet I'm
like I flushed the toilet and she's like
no you didn't there's [ __ ] in the toilet
bowl but I flushed it dad also went to
the bathroom and I was crying because
she doesn't believe me set you up dude I
think about this once a month I flushed
my [ __ ] why would I not flush my [ __ ]
who is like I'm not gonna flush my [ __ ]
who forgets to flush their [ __ ] I said
but Dad went in and Dad's like no I did
it and then Mom but forgot it no but I
was like Dad but he's like I really
didn't think I did it too did you tell
your parents that you think about this
once a month no but now I will